hé alors dis-moi quelque chose nous avons posé les
questions je suis juste curieux je veux dire qui
vous a tous amené en
nous longue histoire beaucoup de rebondissements
sans aucun doute
je suis nicole steele avec le ministère de la
justice dans une ville de 620 000 bpj  les flics ont
signalé plus de 300 000 arrêts de piétons
au cours des cinq dernières années,
vous avez enfermé et battu tellement
de gens que nous ne pouvons pas en mettre 12 dans une boîte,
nous sommes prêts à faire confiance à un composite,
pourrait-il y avoir un moment où une
police  l'officier a fait son travail de
telle manière que vous seriez d'accord avec
la conclusion selon laquelle il devrait être renvoyé pour
comportement abusif ou brutalité
est-il certainement déjà arrivé
nous faisons notre travail qu'est-ce que les gens veulent
que nous arrêtions de faire la police ils veulent que nous
fassions  sans les dommages collatéraux,
vous savez ce que les flics de baltimore qui
n'ont pas de plaintes qu'ils font
tous les jours non,
ils ne sont certainement pas des policiers et vous
ne pouvez pas simplement blâmer les flics que
nous servons les politiciens qui prospèrent en
étant durs  sur le crime et quand ils
m'ont réintégré  ils m'ont mis dans une unité
composée d'un groupe des plus grands escrocs
de tout le [ __ ] de département ces
hommes ici mes détectives nous faisons les choses selon
le livre
monsieur la menace que je
vis c'est un
service de police dysfonctionnel avec une culture qui ressemble  à la
responsabilité comme un mot de quatre lettres je
vous ai parlé il y a des semaines d'une
enquête fédérale il y a toujours une rumeur d'
une enquête fédérale cette merde
n'arrive jamais c'est vulnérable cela
dure depuis longtemps nous venons de
suivre le chef je ne vais pas  pour
perdre mon emploi à cause de ce
regard autour de nous, nous avons construit cette machine où la
moitié du [ __ ] de pays la partie avec de l'
argent et du pouvoir mâche l'autre moitié je
n'avais rien pour commencer à
regarder ça marche j'ai l'impression d'
enseigner à ces jeunes enfants à être  bons
flics honnêtes
reposez-vous sur eux
pas un sale flic
monsieur
vous